foreign
let's go to Andrew in Dayton Ohio what's
up Andrew
hey what's going on Dr John how are you
sir party my brother what's up
oh uh here's I'm just gonna cut to it
how do I grieve
well that's a that's an open-ended broad
question what do you want to grieve
ma'am yeah everything
um
Let's uh
let's go back
um a year ago my mom got sick
and uh
she went in the hospital about six days
later my sister my baby sister got sick
when they get sick what'd they get sick
okay
and
um my mom was in the hospital
42 days my sister 35
um
and uh my sister passed first
cheese it'll be a year coming up this
week
and then
um
my sister had special needs so the she
was she was on a respirator and all the
machines that they hook her up to and
basically
um the doctor wouldn't pull her off the
machine that wasn't doing anything but
keeping her heartbeat until we told our
mom
and asked her permission to take her off
the machine even though my mom was
incapacitated
and so we told her because
you know it was the right thing to do
and
um
six days later my mom passed yeah
and and I and I know it was related to
finding out that she'd lost a child
not no doubt in my mind
and so coming up on a year
and I just
I I don't know that I've grieved it at
all yeah I've I've been sad
I've I've I've cried more times than I
could possibly count
I've lost
hours of sleep every night
um it's created all sorts of other
health problems which is telling me I'm
not doing something right
no it's not it's not hey it's not it's
not Andrew I I think you have you have
grieved it you are grieving it
this is what grief is
it's crying at the weirdest moments it's
waking up in the middle of the night
it's throwing up it's feeling sick
it's looking at like if you have like a
whoop strap it's looking at it and like
you're at 25 recovery for four months
it's like your body's
shuts itself off because it can't it
it's so overwhelming
this is grief man and it's awful but but
then how do I how do I work through it
because it's not something
I mean I've lost people before
um hey dude bro not your mom man not
your mom not your special needs sister
that you've been defending since the day
she was born
like you had a purpose
and your purpose was your sister
and in 30 days it went away
and you've got your mom dude that's a
whole other level that's not like losing
a friend or losing a buddy or losing a
grandparent that's your mother
I've sat with people who are 63 years
old who lose their 80 something year old
parents and they just unspool because
it's their mom it's their dad you know
what I mean this is different and you're
coming up on an anniversary moment and
for whatever reason I I don't know the
physiology of it or the biology of it
but I know that anniversary markers
our bodies tend to just ramp it up
they just turn the heat up on us and
things get a little bit sharper a little
bit low or a little bit darker
and in your case we're ending we're
heading off into the winter season so
things are getting grayer and colder and
it just all works together to say screw
the world right
yeah and can I be honest um and I for
those listening I don't want to hear any
of your political nonsense I got a
friend who's hurting here
um
but when you lose your mom and your
sister
and then a politician gets up and says
this never counted this wasn't ever real
or it's all over now yeah
you're still holding you know you can
look over and see your sister's jacket
hanging on the hook
or when your buddies roll their eyes the
next politician gets up and it's like
I'm running for office and say this
stupid it's like well I lost my mom and
I lost my you know I mean so there's an
extra I'm hearing across the country
especially with coveted losses there's
an extra dose of
hurt on top of it if that makes sense
yeah because it's because my mom like
it's the story of my mom it's the story
of my sister and suddenly it's turned
into a caricature or a drama or a
political move just my mom yeah right
and so there's all sorts of stuff on top
of this
um
here's the best way I can the best
picture I've seen of grief
when your mom passed away and your
sister passed away they cast a long
Shadow over you
and you're sitting in that shadow and
you can see it laid out as though you're
standing in the shadow of a large tree
okay
that shadow length and size will always
be that that big
you lost your mom
what you can't see now is that you will
continue to grow
and in one year five years 10 years 15
years you will be so far out beyond that
shadow the Shadow's still the same size
but you will have developed and grown
and created a new life there will be
Seasons when you find yourself knocked
down sitting up against that tree in
that shadow and it cast Over You Again
and that might be on the five year
anniversary or the 10-year anniversary
you hear a song or you see a special
needs kid that reminds you of your
little sister and your body just Yanks
you back into it it's cool man
it's cool but what you can't see on this
side of it is your growth
I would tell you not to fight it right
now man you're a year in
I would spend here here let me just say
what I would do if I was you is that is
that a fair way to approach this
absolutely
um
I would sit down and write Mom a letter
and I would sit down and write sister a
letter
and if you're really Brave I'd find some
way to read those letters too whether if
you have a sister a sibling or you're
married or something like that I would
read that out loud and in that letter
there's usually three parts one of them
is how pissed off I am that you left me
how mad I am that you're gone
whether that's mad at them mad at God
mad at the doctors mad at whoever
another one is I'm just so sad I miss
you here's what it feels like now that
you're gone
and then the third part of that letter
is
here's what you've missed
I got a new job I got a promotion I'm
letting my hair grow long I've gained 48
pounds right whatever like like the
Astros are going to win the World Series
again right that's me casting well I
hope not I hope not right so it's it's
here's what you've missed and here's
here's why that's important when we
transition to here's what you've missed
we are slowly teaching our bodies and
our minds that it's happened there's a
period at the end of the sentence
and life is continuing to move
and over time you write letters about
what you've missed how much I miss you
and those letters will get more and more
infrequent
and they'll get shorter
and you'll find yourself laughing again
and then you're going to find yourself
have you already done this where you
find yourself just laughing your butt
off dude like you've something so funny
and it's usually super profane like you
wouldn't say in front of your mom but
you're laughing and then you feel guilty
for having joy for laughing yeah yeah
yeah yeah
notice when you feel guilty laughing
notice when you feel guilty after sex
notice when you feel guilty about some
of these pleasurable moments in life
that suddenly you think wait a minute I
shouldn't be having pleasure because I'm
still because they died right and
don't beat yourself up over it but just
notice it and then exhale and say no
I'm allowed to smile my mom would want
me to be having a good time
my sister would want me to smile
you know what I mean yeah
yeah I struggle with the different roles
I have to carry right now
um I'm I'm a husband okay I'm a dad okay
um I've got uh
two other biological sisters and then an
adopted special needs sister okay and
then I've got my dad
and then my mom's mom is still alive so
I feel the burden of responsibility to
help her because that was Mom's role
and
it's
I mean it's just challenging it's it's
overwhelming sometimes
here's and I want to flip the whole
thing over okay
okay
you can only do that type of heavy
lifting if Andrew comes first
if Andrew's physical health comes first
you're sleeping and you're eating right
you're moving your body you're
exercising a couple times a week
you have some friends that you're
talking to
you get buddies together once a week and
you'll go to throw darts or you go I
don't know build something play guitar
whatever it is but you get a group
together
only then you go to church you go back
you get reconnected with faith community
whatever that looks like for you only
then
are you reinforced enough to then be the
dad that your kids need and by the way
hopefully you've told your kids how sad
you are
oh absolutely absolutely good don't Rob
them of this moment of watching here's
what a man who loves his daughter feels
and is going through don't take that
from him okay be honest with them
otherwise they're going to feel you're
angst and they're going to feel your
distance and they're going to blame
themselves for it
give give that gift to them to let them
watch
I tell them all the time
um I I got I mean my kids are 12 and 10.
perfect and so they're they're at that
age of understanding and all of the
things that they have to process through
um you know we try to protect them when
we were in the hospital where they were
in the hospital
um I was driving an hour every day to go
see them and
you know trying to keep keep them from
all of the information and
um we learned afterwards that that was
probably not the best way to do that
sure so here we are so you're doing a
good job of communicating now right
yeah we're we're on it now we we learned
the hard way good good
and so
can I say something hard man
please I'll say something something good
and then I'll say something hard okay
whenever we lose somebody that we love
especially they were hurting as badly as
your sister and your mom are hurting and
the ventilator passing is is brutal you
saw it firsthand right yeah yeah
one of my jobs when I did crisis
response was if somebody had like let's
say they'd lost a kid
say A kid had died by Suicide and mom
was coming home and she was coming to
the house my job was actually to meet
Mom in the four year of that home or in
the front yard and not let Mom come back
and see the kid
and well here's why
because
here is my standard line that I always
gave and it wasn't a line it was the
truth
you don't want this to be the last
picture of your son or daughter in your
mind
you want that last picture the time
y'all hugged when he left your house
that time at Thanksgiving when you were
throwing marshmallows at each other you
don't want this last picture because it
freeze frames in your mind and here's
what we miss they're not hurting anymore
okay the last time you saw your sister
she was in Hell the last time you saw
your mom you watched her
dissolve like just dissipate in front of
you and listen brother they're not
hurting anymore
okay
yeah
and it's making peace with oh yeah
they're finally free
they are free free free
and it's sitting in that for a minute
because right now your body is still
trying to make sure everything's okay
with them on the ventilator they're not
there anymore here's the hard thing my
brother they're gone
and no amount of work or trying to
Cobble together more things to throw on
your shoulders
is going to make their life any more
okay they're gone
yeah and it's been able to open your
hands up and for the first time in a
year drop your shoulders down
tell your sisters I need some help tell
your dad how are you man I can help you
but I can't I can't carry you
see the difference there I do okay
yeah
um
I have my good days of course you do bro
you're not broke hey you are not broken
you're not malfunctioning you're you're
a son who loved his mom and you're a
dope brother Who Loved a sister
that's what you are and that means it
hurts
so how do I handle
so when these moments hit and and uh
being perfectly honest you're the first
person I've talked to in a year outside
of close friends okay so I feel like I
need more help than what I'm getting but
how do I handle the
those moments where
I'm wrestling with the regret you know
the Miss Thanksgiving the the time I
blew my mouth to go hang with my buddies
you know whatever the story may be you
know those moments come up
and then they're just
crushing sometimes that's right that's
right and so there's there's two ways to
move forward from this number one is
when those thoughts pop into your mind
understand you have a choice
you have a choice to meditate on that
lightning bolt that pops in remember
that time you blew mom off for a text
message
and literally say out loud not doing
that
not doing it at your brain trying to
meditate on the things on the negativity
so that it can prevent hurt in the
future and it doesn't prevent hurt in
the future it's just your brain trying
to do the best it can because it's got a
very primitive operating system on it
that says look bear run from bear watch
out for Bears right yeah and so those
lightning bolts pop into your mind when
you're walking down the street and you
remember that time you snapped at your
special needs sister because she was
driving you crazy
and you go nope
and here's the key here's the second key
you have an immediate thought to replace
that with
a time you and your little sister
laughed so hard you thought you were
gonna both vomit on each other that time
you and your mom got into a donut eating
contest and you saw that nine-year-old
girl come out of her in a weird way
or the time your mom cussed at you and
it just slipped out and you laughed
right let's go to that and here's what
will happen in short order if you will
do that work
because you weren't a bad son you're a
human being
if you will do that work in a shorter
amount of time than you think your body
will change the default setting to every
time you think of them they will be
filled with light and joy not oh my God
they just died
okay okay it is saying nope not doing it
I'm not going to meditate on the
negative I remember that time Mom fill
in the blank did something hilarious or
I'm calling Dad
I'm called that see how he's doing and
here's the other big boy thing you gotta
do
you got to sit down with your wife in
the next 48 hours okay and tell her I
have not been honest with you for a year
I've tried to be tough I've tried to
carry all this I felt a ton of
responsibility and I'm heartbroken
because I miss my sister
and I'm heartbroken because I miss my
mom
and there's going to be moments in the
next six months while I'm healing that
I'm not gonna be able to carry it all
and I'm gonna ask you I may lean over
and say hey I need some help today
and that would be one of the greatest
gifts you give your wife
because she's been feeling insane and
helpless sitting on her own hands the
last year and finally her husband's
gonna say I'm not Superman I'm calling
reality as it is
can I get some help and she's gonna say
God yes I'm ready for you is that fair
that's absolutely Fair because I think
she would she's been the one telling me
to get some help that's right um because
she here's why
she feels you not sleeping and she feels
you sitting at the kitchen table four
feet from I mean four inches from her
and four thousand miles away from her
it feels it and she doesn't know how to
bridge that Gap and so she's asking you
to walk across it and if you sat down
and had that moment of vulnerability
tonight
cancel whatever plans you got tonight
and take her out to dinner and just say
I haven't been honest with you I've been
trying to carry all this myself and I'm
sorry
I need some I need you to pick up some
slack for a season
oh my gosh what a gift that would be for
your home my brother what a gift
um
I'll say it one more time you're not
broken man
you're just in it
um do sit down and write your mom that
letter do sit down and write your sister
that letter read it to your wife if you
can read it to your sisters if you can
have them write letters and y'all can
get together for the one year
anniversary of their passing and have
another
celebration slash day of morning
let your kids hear those letters
bring people into this
and you're great you will begin to grow
and stand Beyond this Shadow that's my
promise my brother hang on the line I'm
going to send you a copy of own your
past change your future you've you've
been through it and now we're gonna ask
ourselves what do we do next and I got
you thanks for calling my brother